all britain has recorded its largest
daily increase in coronavirus deaths on
wednesday nearly 2,500 people have now
died have covered 19 the government has
been criticised for carrying out too few
tests compared to other countries
authorities have opened a series of
emergency field hospitals across the
country to deal with the massive surge
in cases DW Chartres Potts reports from
London the finishing touches to London's
newest hospital 4,000 bets to treat
Kovac 19 patients and ISA pressure on
Britain's National Health Service which
has far fewer bets intensive care units
and ventilators than most of its
European neighbors what you see here is
a mass mobilisation taking place right
across the country but also at these new
Nightingale hospitals this has been an
extraordinary team effort on the part of
nurses and doctors and therapists and
pharmacists across London but also
volunteers and paramedics and people
returning to health 20,000 retired
doctors and nurses have returned to work
most of them could be needed to cover
this new hospital alone
meanwhile critical care beds across
London are filling up doctors and nurses
are bracing for a continuous tsunami of
Korona patients and they're frightened
of what's to come they don't have the
proper equipment to protect themselves
and there is a serious lack of testing
one in four hospital doctors is self
isolating at home at the moment because
they can't get tested just at a time
when they are needed the most so far
only 2,000 out of half a million
frontline NHS staff in England have been
tested for the virus now the government
has promised to use all spare
coronavirus tests for medical personnel
British industry is doing its part in
the crisis instead of vacuum cleaners
Dyson is now building thousands of
ventilators as well call make us from
the world of Formula One racing like
mercy descent McLaren despite these
efforts experts say there won't be
enough ventilators ready in time but
people and Britain are still proud of
their Health Service NHS here is I feel
more prepared than most countries that I
know of I work in the hospital little
marvellous job yeah absolutely fantastic
I can't see any problems to be honest
here at the moment this started before
Christmas in China and we should have
been preparing before that but what can
we do now
just get on with that space the worst is
yet to come
the peak is expected to reach the UK
after Easter so these next weeks will be
the most crucial test for the NHS since
its founding after the Second World War